what is your advice for anyone who is
in these affected countries at the
moment should they leave immediately
that will depend on their personal
circumstances but the broad advice steve
is you know if you're there
you can finish and enjoy your holiday
there is now this quarantine
um issue that i think people have been
aware this may well come along
unfortunately this virus doesn't play
ball and as the french prime minister
jean castillo said himself france has
been heading the wrong way
and we've seen a 66 increase
in the last week alone uh test positive
cases in in france
um so people will look at their own
situations i think a lot of people would
have been aware
that this was a possibility uh in france
and in some of these other countries
what procedures are in place to get
people home because you've given them
well just over 24 hours notice just
under 24 hours now and yet eurostar
saying
you know they they haven't got any seats
available at the moment we're not quite
sure what the situation is
with planes at the moment but you know
if people want to get home
can they actually get home yes we as you
say
we've provided a bit more notes it's
actually four a.m saturday uh
night um there's a little bit more
notice than there was for example on
in spain which is where where i was
actually when i came back and and had to
quarantine at the end of that
um uh because the rate is uh just a bit
behind where
spain was at the time and of course the
thing with france
is that there are three different ways
to travel you can take the
air but you can also go by um sea and
you'd also go by
and the tunnel but you know clearly um
quite a lot of people
may be trying to return immediately the
advice from all the travel operators is
very clear
to contact them in advance don't just
turn up um because uh you'll almost
certainly be
uh disappointed and uh and it will just
create uh uh
accuse which uh no one wants to see um
but uh as i say i think given what's
happened this summer given what's
already happened in places like
spain and um the vast amount of coverage
about
concerns in france and elsewhere no one
will be entirely surprised
but i do sympathize with people as i've
been there myself
and ended up having to quarantine as a
result
in terms of the the the potential threat
from
from these countries is now on this list
and the threat to the uk economy as well
of
of the potential of of lots of people
being in quarantine and off work for an
extra fortnight
wouldn't it be a sensible move to
instead of just quarantining people
actually getting people tested on their
return isn't that doable
well testing on return is certainly
something that you know we've always
said we
keep a very close eye on the science
behind those things testing on return
isn't quite as straightforward as it
sounds
because if you test somebody who's
asymptomatic in other words
they don't think they've got anything
but may in fact have it on day one on
their return
then it would probably only uh capture a
very small percentage
and some uh scientists have suggested
perhaps only seven percent of
actual cases now clearly you need to
have a system which is more accurate
than that before you can say to people
you've now been tested and you don't
need to quarantine and
of course these are things that we're
reviewing all of the time but the
absolute paramount thing here
is is you know public safety we have
worked so hard as a country
to get the numbers down we have seen it
lift uh you know across europe it's
really important that we try our hardest
to prevent that from
creating the problems that we're all so
familiar with
here in the past and so you know we do
need to
act and i think the public have a right
to expect us to act as soon as the
figures justify it
and as i say the french figures in
particular 66
rise uh in just a week a 50 over 50
rise in in holland so we will continue
to keep these this under review
sometimes adding countries we're safe to
do so and sometimes i'm afraid removing
countries
where we can no longer do so
the boss of heathrow saying in effect
that this you the quarantine regulations
as they currently stand with more and
more countries being added
to that list uh is strangling the uk
economy now that's a valid point isn't
it at a time when we are
desperately trying to get the economy up
and running again
yeah and i speak to the boss of heathrow
that's john holland k uh quite
regularly along with the the other
airport bosses and airline bosses
and of course the right no one wants to
see a situation where quarantine's in
in place no everyone wants business to
be able to operate and and sell
internationally in the rest of it
i'm afraid this virus is just a reality
that we
don't control and where we do control it
in this country we certainly control it
less
abroad and so it is reality public
health has to be the first priority
um and that's why we've at least got
travel corridors um
open and still operating to i think well
over 70
countries and we do add countries in as
as things improve but it's a dynamic
situation
and i don't think that anybody watching
this would want us to
do anything other than protect public
health and public safety and i'm afraid
that does mean
where we see countries breach a sort of
certain level
of cases uh and a certain level of um
of positivity in those cases then we
have no real choice but to act and
that's what we've had to do here
in terms of protecting public health as
you mentioned saying the government's
doing everything it can
on that well i mean one of the clear
messages which has come out over the
last few weeks of course is wearing face
masks
under certain circumstances going into
shops going into crowded places
and the the fine for not doing so has
now doubled to 3
200 pounds perhaps a deterrent but who
on earth
is enforcing this yeah i mean you must
know you know we all we've all
wandered around town centres and shops
and supermarkets and seen
plenty of people who just don't abide by
these rules
so first of all actually we're not just
doubling fine to 3200 there's a ladder
now so the fine would double on each
occasion
what you tend to get actually with these
things is a very high level
of compliance i was just being looking
at the latest and statistics 89
of people on public transport are
wearing
face coverings which is extremely high
and don't forget actually of the other
11
um there are people who legitimately
have reasons not to so
that's that's even an even higher
compliance so the most people are doing
the right thing and complying
but what you tend to get is a few people
who just think that this doesn't apply
to them
um we've had uh to give you some numbers
91 000
interventions that will be from the
british transport police
transport for london network rail just
usually just reminding people of your
face mask and people oh yeah and
put it on so we've had a lot of
interventions there have been um
341 fixed penalty
notices and what we notice of course is
quite a lot of the same people will
continue to you know just think that
they can
carry on ignoring it and so it's for
those people that the fines will keep
doubling and doubling up to a maximum of
3200
but compliance generally is very hard
high and most people want to do the
right thing most people want
remember when you wear a mask you're
helping to protect your your fella
fellow passenger or
in a shop um other shoppers and so on
and so forth so
it's important that people do adhere to
it and this gives just some extra teeth
to that
um can we return to to
your remit particularly i mean looking
at the obviously there's this
terrible train accident in scotland
and now we we know that a train was
turned back in kent yesterday because of
a landslide we understand
that network rail has ordered
inspections across the whole
of the uk rail network
what is going on here is is there a real
concern about train safety now
first of all i was in stone stone haven
in scotland um yesterday and i went to
see the crash site
uh myself and met some of the people who
uh were the emergency services first on
the scene
um absolute harrowing um stories and
um you know just heart goes out to
people
and families involved in that terrible
terrible incident i ordered network rail
um as a result of the flash floods that
we've been having
and the extreme weather and to carry out
that resilience test across
the whole network which will have caused
them to be
additionally cautious uh in places like
kent and i've actually ordered a full
report from them with an interim on my
desk on september the 1st
to check the resilience of the network
what makes this so shocking actually in
part is we haven't had deaths through
derailment i think the last person who
lost their life in that way was
13 years ago and and so it's
very very unusual on our network we want
to keep it safe i actually represent
um hatfield uh which was the scene of a
terrible
train crash and right next to potter's
bar um
those bad days were behind us and we
want to make sure that continues and
that's why i've asked network rail to do
this work very urgently
but where does that leave us in terms of
our confidence
in getting on the train i mean if if
that resilience testing needs to be
carried out and yes perhaps a
a very sensible precaution but for
people who are having to get on the
train
particularly monday to friday
are there concerns well we'll look up
but put it this way i would definitely
get on the
train um straight away um just to put
this into proportion 1
700 people die on our roads every single
year usually without very much publicity
at all but 1
700 people as i mentioned it's 13 years
since a single
fatality uh from a derailment on our
railway so that
it's a very proportionately safe way to
travel nonetheless you know when you see
something as i did yesterday and i flew
over
in a helicopter over the crash site at
stonehaven it is
absolutely um you know horrific uh to
see something
like uh like that sort of derailment
take place
we need to get to the bottom i need to
allow the rail accident investigation
branch to do their work
uh but we need to find out exactly what
happened we will get to the bottom of it
in the meantime i think a a quick
resilience
uh test particularly since we've got
such extreme
uh weather uh at the moment such a you
know hot summer and then these flash
floods
uh it clearly has the potential to lead
to greater dangers and that's why i've
asked network rail to act immediately
um look on a totally different issue but
it's got to be addressed
and the a level issue i mean obviously
we
we've seen what's happened in scotland
with their results slightly different
exams
and saying they got things wrong with
the
the way things were moderated downgraded
there's a lot of concern over what's
happened with a level results and we
know it's not a perfect situation i
can never be at the moment but there's
certainly got to be some movement on a
very swift appeals process here hasn't
there i mean
one of your your colleagues lucy allen
has called the the system
fundamentally flawed this algorithm that
was used to sort of moderate everything
another mp one of your colleagues is
suggesting
one of their local schools are gonna try
to appeal their entire
set of results for a levels this year
and on top of that you've got the gcses
coming out next week so you're going to
have it all over again
there's got to be an appeals process put
in place really quickly hasn't there
yeah well i should declare my vested
interest i've got twins in this
household who will
next week be getting their gcse results
and obviously parents and
and of course pupils in particular uh
will um be watching and
wanting to know that this is fair and
first of all i should say
congratulations to all the
uh a level students yesterday uh 97
of the grades that were awarded were the
center of the assessment
grade so we've put in place a triple
lock because
you know clearly with coronavirus
it was impossible to carry out the exams
as normal everyone understands that
but this triple lock actually means that
people are able to
challenge the grades in a variety of
different ways including um
looking back at the mocks including
retaking the exam actually
so um and actually when i look at the
detail 179
000 uh places have now been confirmed
for university
uh that's up by more than 9 000 on last
year
so there are a lot of students who've
done phenomenally well
have now had their places confirmed at
university and of course there's
that triple lock so people who need to
challenge the results that are still
able to do that and ultimately even able
to take the exam in the autumn
okay grant chaps appreciate your time
this morning thank you